Sáng nay ngày 11h năm 2018, công an tình vô Chí Minh đã thông tin về vụ trái tại Phương Phú Thọ hả khiến những người tìm mạng.
Cô thị và lúc 20 mốt dở nếu mình từ Phú Thủng qua, phòng cạnh rất phòng trái trưa trái và cứu nạn cứu hộ,
công an tình vô Chí Minh nhận tin báo về việc sế ra trái tại chú cưa được lập phương Phú Thọ hả khi phương Phú Chí Minh.
Phòng cạnh rất phòng trái trưa trái và cứu nạn cứu hộ đã nhìn trong trường hay lực lượng.
Phương tình khần chương để hiệt chương, công lực lượng công an phường phủ thọ hả và các đình bị khá có linh quan tổ chức trái và cứu nạn cứu hộ.
Đông thời, đông chi chủ tự kiến bán nhân tình phố cùng lãnh đạo công an thành phố và lãnh đạo phòng cạnh rất phòng trái trái và cứu nạn cứu nạn cứu hộ.
Đám trái được giập tất lúc hành hai dờ mấy phút cùng ngày và khu trái không để trái lán, bà người được lực lượng cứu nạn cứu hộ đưa rằng ngoại át hoàn.
Vũ trái khiến tả người từ vong và trái mục phần dịch tích cân hộ cùng một số phương vịt và sự trong gia đình.
Hình các đơn vị có linh quan đạo khẩn trường đưa trái làm sói nhìn vụ trái.
Đông thời, phối hợp các bạn ảnh bỗ trợ khó khẩu khẩu khẩu khẩu khẩu khẩu khẩu quà đông viên gia đình nạn nhân ủng địt cuộc sống.